I feel like the other way to look at it
is like thanks for putting some more
life into this song and but that's what
eventually happened yeah cuz like there
did you see the Grammys Tracy Chapman
perform with uh this country singer who
she has a song called Fast Car from like
1988 I know J JC yeah yeah and uh this
this country singer covered it wow and
like it was a huge country song but they
did it at the grammies and so now Tracy
Chapman's song from 1988 no it's number
one it's number onee it's crazy it's
like believe me I was telling my man the
other day like and this this not no no b
or nothing yeah but um me owning my own
publishing everybody calls me so if it
was for all the 50 Cent shows you know
whatever my placements they got to call
me direct I was telling my man
that music I mean the weekend is one of
the most streaming artists in the world
100% right so him and Metro
boomman did I don't want to know yeah
yep which is you a customer mhm right y
only owe 4% of that 4% of that of that
record right
4% of the
original of no of that record of Metro
boomman yeah of of of your a customer on
that song so you own 4% of creeping of
of
right listen every four months guess how
much it brings
in $200,000 220
wow that's
crazy y y yo but that's 240 but 240
that's crazy how he was on the money
he's in it yeah
4% Eric talk about track track wait hold
on so let me get this straight so when
you because you have to hear the song
first before you clear it yes even when
they when they did the Mad singer and
the Mad somebody on the Mad singer sung
did the record yeah mad singer called me
wow everybody has to call because again
everybody's not fortunate cuz
luckily Leo con his brother made me made
me
me and what them made me me so I didn't
have to sell the publishing cuz people
sell publishing when they when they they
need to get the money so luckily I was
able to survive without doing that for
you like uh
I think most people don't understand the
how important the pub game is because we
always are pushed like well the
streaming only pays this if you get a
million streams it's like 3,800 bucks
but like the real money is really in the
pub right like if you can like own your
publishing this back this up yeah even
though streaming might be less than one
cent it's still more money being made
than you signed to a
label it's still more money being made
if you don't sign to a label is what
you're saying if you signed to a label
and you and and and and and you are
independent
streaming you is a chance that you can
make more money than being on a major
exactly yeah for sure even with the less
than one penny yeah it's it's rough cuz
you I mean but but but but people don't
know if you're not in the game you
wouldn't know that I have a streaming
company so I I I I'm witness to what it
makes right but on the pub side though
like cuz I feel like the publishing side
of music is not talked about enough and
I also feel like oh no people know that
why you what you've seen all arguments
with the locks and puff and everybody
with publishing that's a always been a
big deal no I mean I'm just talking
about this new these new kids man oh
they don't have a clue they have no idea
because it's a 360 Asma they'll just
come in they'll be like how much is my
advantage yeah that's it yeah and then
they be like oh [__] I don't know my
masters of my Pub [__] or they'll rush
into a pub deal they they'll they'll get
one placement and then they everybody
here what Kevin's talking about because
Kev don't got to do this but he is doing
this he's just trying to not to to to to
to downplay y'all but to let y'all know
what y'all have to do because this thing
is not going to is not a lasting thing
at this time this we living in moments
times of popularity where things are
fast food every new every hour something
is coming yep yeah and if you catch one
placement as a producer someone's going
to offer you a c-pub deal not an admin
deal and that c-pub deal it could be I
mean that means you're full partners
with a publishing company and it could
be 10 years it could be imper it it
could be a lot of different things
whatever people talk about the 401K or
your retirement plan this is what
publishing is it's it's your life if
you're able to have some of it please
grab as much as you can cuz you're going
to get that mailbox money every all the
time it it never stops and then all of a
sudden you might catch a placement like
I just told you yeah which is crazy how
many years later I know but but it
happens but this I'm just giving you one
yeah this happens all the time I'm just
giving you one thing about having
publishing and what can do for you for
sure man um for you on on this uh on
this new album how cool was it to uh
give the fans I mean I know we're going
to we're when when's the album drop
April's I think first week in April
first week of April but how cool is it
going to be to give the fans some new
EPMD after all these years yeah I mean
it's so crazy how how the label be like
yo I like the EPMD record and I'm like
are you saying because of me you know
what I'm saying but I think that I just
think that the fans are going to be
happy if I was on there burping right
because it's a is just a because it's a
new EPMD song yeah or new Cyprus Hills
right you know so people oh yeah the mob
deep [__] is crazy because because
prodigyy so so but again when people
hear it they like oh okay and then
hopefully I did my job for it to feel
like it's supposed to feel like cuz
don't forget our
colleagues don't don't go because they
either scared or like you said the
records don't come out correctly right
right right right right you know so
hopefully I was able to correct it to
too like when I was when I was here with
Dre as you see on my on Instagram when I
was me and Dre was in the studio and
everybody know it went
viral me and Dre made five records you
know and and he made three in one night
crazy you know off of my production
though and then
I did we did another one with
Snoop that supposed to be on the new on
the new Snoop record and and I also did
one with him that me and him rhymed on
which was crazy wow you know um but
again Kevin it's just a blessing because
I don't want to I I never talk so I hate
to be big big up myself cuz I'm not used
to doing that I always been introvert
always been quiet but again at the end
of the day a lot of dope [__] that has
happened in the last couple of years for
this to be what this is don't for this
is only volume one so is is it going to
be a Duos thing after of course Dynamic
du is my my brand I mean of course so so
so so now it's a brand that me make it
so I'm already in in like um saying you
know um you know with with with um
saying about the Larry Junes and the and
and the source Walkers and all these
people that I'm looking at to do music
with you know the the the the Cordes the
Freddy Gibs all these other you work
with Freddy yet I work with Freddy back
in 2014 okay when he he was on inter
scope or no no 2014 no no no that was uh
that was uh that was around the time he
put out uh
bandana or pinata yeah but that was I
was there before that I've been he's
been one of my best friends since about
2010 remember the DJ that was um what's
the DJ name the one that um that he was
signed to First in 2008 2009 the the ski
yeah I'm back he working with ski yeah
yeah on that time so I listen kev's one
of the goats man no rappers that wrapped
didn't come to me that's fine none if
you was rapping if you was a rapping ass
[__] you know what I mean you
had no no because only a few of us did
production right you only gonna go for
to a few people right that's that's
crazy